our people cannot sleep without having
suit as a thing to worry
stereo is actually terrible
you wake up in the morning to black
particles everyone you meet in port
harcourt has stories about what they
call black soot caused by the
manufacturing and consumption of these
fuel products in the illegal refineries
this black soot has been falling from
the sky in a region key to nigeria's
economy for about five years
oil theft known as bunkering and the
refining of its spoils is worsening the
damage from decades of fossil fuel
exploitation creating one of the world's
most severe ecological disasters
the oil illegally bankrupt is a sabotage
to the economy of the nation
it is very dangerous
to the health of whatever and we cannot
sit down and see our people dying
[Music]
our sacred forests our homes
have to give way to oil wells
and no one gets much benefit
but stealing and refining oil is a major
source of income in a country where
wages are meager and more than half of
working age adults are either unemployed
or underemployed
many believe that efforts to stop the
illegal trade will be in vain and that
the health of the people of the niger
delta will continue to suffer
imagine a resident of potako
who inhales his suit every second
in 24 hours seven days a week 30 days in
the month and for years now we are dying
slowly but surely and our lifespan is
reducing every day
[Music]
half a century after prospecting began
in nigeria shell and bp struck crude in
to 1956 nigeria is free in 1960 when the
country declared independence from the
british empire citizens were hopeful
that their newfound resource would bring
prosperity to their nation
but the years following would be
volatile giving way to civil war and a
succession of military coups
nevertheless nigeria established itself
as a major oil exporter but this came at
a price
there have been many many years in the
last 40 or 50 years where
oil sales have accounted for more than
90 percent of nigeria's export earnings
and when oil has contributed well over
50 percent of government income all this
easy money from oil and gas meant that
the government neglected other areas of
the economy that should have been key to
nigeria's development such as
agriculture and basic manufacturing and
mining
aside from oil companies and a
privileged few nigerians in business and
politics the country as a whole has seen
minimal benefits from being africa's
biggest petrol state
one only has to visit the niger delta to
see the extent to which the wealth
generated by the deposits there has not
been shared equally
it's a region in which most people live
in really quite impoverished conditions
there isn't much in the way of
employment and you will not find
anyone who lives in the delta who thinks
that their people have got a fair deal
out of 60 something years of oil
production
we drink this river water
then if those don't have money you drink
this water then if you have money you
buy people and drink
in the 90s in a area called agony land a
very charismatic activist called ken
sarah
launched a campaign against shells
operations in the area accusing it of
causing immense levels of environmental
degradation
these demonstrations caused shells
operations to shut down and exit the
area but the activists were met with
swift and violent action at the hands of
nigeria's then military dictatorship
[Music]
[Applause]
let amity is a lawyer activist and
survivor of that tumultuous era
ken and this other of my colleagues were
executed
i stood trial with skin and i was lucky
that i was found not guilty and released
the fate of kensarowewa and his comrades
laid the path for a violent backlash in
the 2000s where militants who prefer to
call themselves agitators blew up
pipelines attacked oil and gas
facilities and kidnapped employees
most times people i ask them why are
they resorting to armed struggle
and the people ask me why should i
you guys went non-violently and you were
killed so we are not going to wait to be
killed before we carry the amps and
that's how
militants took over the rest of the
region
people were angry because they were not
getting what they thought were the just
rewards from the oil from their land
and they decided to sabotage the
pipelines and all that
[Applause]
we met with a former militant leader a
former agitator leader who goes by the
nom daguerre of osama bin laden
that meant because of when we used to
blow the pipe and do all those things
that was our bush name
[Music]
we are suffering you will see charcoal
everywhere
seriously
you can see the stain on the coast our
objective that time is that they cannot
collect our oil
without
making our place okay for us
you see
if they are getting the oil from us they
should make our place fine
[Music]
the agony land native was one of the
leaders in a loose coalition of heavily
armed militias that carried out a
campaign which at its height reduced
nigeria's oil production by up to 40
percent
this violence became so bad in the late
2000s and was having such a negative
impact on nigeria's daily oil output
that the then president offered the main
leaders and their men an amnesty program
the leaders got properties and lucrative
business opportunities for disarming and
their men got monthly stipends which
they still received to this day
now he prefers to present himself as a
peacemaker
[Applause]
and make sure that
people
all the place have peace
they will empower us
they will find job for our voice
then they will make sure that the
environment here is okay
but the environment is anything but okay
and many of the jobs that have been
created are in the black market
much of the crude oil that is stolen
from pipelines makes its way to illegal
refineries that are situated deep in the
creeks and deep in the forests of the
niger delta far from the prying eyes of
the government
it's at these sites where the entire
industry of illegal refining which is
commonly known in the delta as bow fire
takes place
the products that they produce in these
refining sites are sold to
traders who go and sell these products
throughout the niger delta and
throughout the wider country
the government currently estimates that
up to 150 000 barrels of oil are stolen
every day equivalent to about 10
of official production
some industry figures estimate the scale
of the theft is even greater
so what we are seeing today
is
the flip side of the same militancy
instead of breaking pipelines
just despite the government and the oil
companies we break pipelines to make
money
through illegal refining
the tapping of pipelines stealing of oil
and the emissions from the refining
process have added another complication
to the region's environmental crisis and
as expected it's affecting the health
and well-being of local inhabitants
we first observed these immediate
refining issues that culminated into the
appearance of the suit in potter court
and its metropolis sometime in 2017 when
it became very much visible
and since then we've been having issues
with respiration issues with their
hearts issues with the liver issues with
the kidneys of residents of potakota and
its environs
the complaints are variable
they are not static they are just too
many
and this is what we inhale every day if
we bait our body charcoal
if we step on the ground everywhere
shaco
this issue of black soot is not new it's
been around for a couple of years but
the governor told us that he was obliged
to launch his war against illegal
refining because the problem had become
so bad
what we did
was from our own vigilante
to monitor what is going on
i cannot tell you here alternatively
that we have completely
stopped it
but i can see
that we have been able
to reduce
the level
of these illegal activities
if identifying your site i'll just write
since launching his crusade the
governor's task force claimed to have
found and destroyed at least 480 of the
so-called ovens used for cooking the
crude oil
the governor declared a total war on
illegal refinery to keep the people of
river state alive you can't drink from
the water you can't do anything from
this place because of these activities
of the illegal oil finally this is the
roots they bring in their speed boats
here on drums and barrels yes emporos
you can smell the uh the oil
yes it's crude
all our rivers here are gone the
environment is messed up we have
published names we are also conducting
house to house arrest
when we visited a site which had
recently been dismantled and destroyed
by the local government it really gave
us a sense of the size of this industry
in this very small area if we don't
destroy the heart of the activity which
is the illegal refinement centers
then the crude will be cooked the suit
will still be on the air and you just be
scratching this office we have done what
the governor has told us to do and it
has viewed that huge amount of results
that was one small area in rivers state
so if there was that many ovens just
there it gives an impression of how many
might be elsewhere throughout the delta
fine face dom nominee is a local
activist who spent years fighting for
environmental justice for the residents
of the river state
the entire ninja data is the most
polluted part of the aids anywhere in
the world
this community has been massively
polluted by hydrocarbon
from the activities of multinational oil
companies
the people of oguni are dying as a
result of pollution if you test and
average a gunny man you will see that he
or she has been polluted in their lungs
because of what they inhale every day in
the polluted environments that they live
in nigeria data will have well over 40
million people 23 million of these are
young people and a lot of these young
people have a lesser percentage that are
gainfully engaged
the use of the niger data have waited
for the oil companies to provide jobs
for them they are not getting the jobs
when they go to them to seek for
opportunities to be able to be employed
they are not getting it
fred baragpora says he's been involved
in the black market of oil refining
since 2016 but has had to stop due to
the recent crackdown
his cousin favor said she used to sell
the fuel and suffers from multiple
ailments that she blames on inhaling oil
fumes
we don't have any mix of livelihood we
don't have any support
since we don't have any other means
we don't have any usher on that to risk
your life
and other of my friends are going into
the business more
and the vision is killing a lot of
people more
if you get to the mortuary you see what
we are saying
but see we don't have any option we go
into the business that is killing us
you can see my sister favorite suffering
because i have no option not to go for
the business for her to be sustained a
little
if this thing
started
i cannot stand up
i cannot do anything again
so
i am praying
pleading for the government
you should do something about it
when i saw the woman she's having
anasaka that means that generalized body
swelling there has been oil spilled
there before everywhere
if you look at the woman she could
really breathe
she couldn't walk because her heart is
feeling
congestive cardiac failure
she has the classical features of almost
all all the major complications of the
suit his manifest want to check your
heart
your liver and your kidney
help me and get me out of this trouble
and be sickness
i still want to live
i have children to take care of
i have family to take care of
the lifespan of residents of portacot
it is reducing and to keep reducing for
as long as we still breathe in this
polluted air occasioned by the suit
according to amnesty international
hundreds of oil spills occur in the
niger delta every year and they are
rarely properly cleaned up
while most go unnoticed by the outside
world two recent incidents did capture
public attention
[Music]
in november 2021 a well exploded spewing
oil and gas into the surrounding rivers
and mangrove swamps for almost 40 days a
meaningful cleanup has yet to take place
a few months later a storage tanker blew
up just off nigeria's coast
the environment ministry says it was
holding up to 60 thousand barrels of oil
the environment has been irredeemably
damaged
and yet nothing is happening no food has
been held to account no government
official has been have been sacked no
action has been taken with respect to
you know holding people accountable for
failure to do the rest take care of
their responsibilities
in 2010 the united nations environment
program produced a report about oil
spills and environmental damage in the
agony land recommending a five-year
cleanup project estimated to cost one
billion dollars and funded primarily by
shell
a government agency called the
hydrocarbon pollution remediation
project or high prep has been put in
charge of the cleanup effort and awarded
its first contracts in 2018.
while high prep does publish regular
activity updates agony land residents
claim not to have seen substantial
progress as of yet
12 years later there's a lot of concern
about the progress of the project and
activist groups environmental groups
accused the
people managing the project of not
operating in a particularly transparent
way
we had a lot of hope
and some sense of satisfaction that at
least we have achieved something
but several years after i'm afraid that
i cannot say that there's a cleanup
they haven't even finished cleaning up
the sites that were classified as simple
and are yet to even give out the
contracts to clean up the areas
categorized as complex hyprep did not
respond to several requests per comment
not much have been achieved in oguni
that was supposed to serve as a model
for other parts of the niger data and i
think they need to go back to the
drawing board and be able to carry out
the environmental remediation of orgoni
and then extend it to other parts of
reverse data and other parts of the data
because if they keep delaying this
process the lifespan of an average ogoni
reverse manager determine we continue to
reduce because we live in polluted
environment every day of our lives
you